all right I want to bring these two
roles together so there's the Bitcoin
crypto world and then there's the legacy
issues that you described I have been
found you've been pounding the table
about bonds and everything for a while
I've been pounding the table that every
public pension in the United States
should have 1% exposure to Bitcoin as a
hedge depends on your age okay
okay explain why age because the
expected future return and the risk
profile don't match for a 65 year old
baby boomer because they have to divest
of assets then they need to own bonds
and I need to just understand that
they've got what they've got don't
speculate
now now here's my argument or counter to
that is they're not gonna own a hundred
percent bonds right because that just
the way that the investment mandates are
of the pensions etc and so instead what
they can do is they can put one percent
allocation to a non correlated asset
where the value drug is okay I get the
theory why I just don't think it is if
you're the 65 year old what I don't
think the risk profile of the asset is
right for a 65 year old because the risk
profile of Bitcoin is the volatility of
the asset so they could probably take
some another asset with a potential
future expected return that is maybe
better I would take let's say VC because
you can invest in this space and I think
you'll have a better expected return for
those kind of people that versus the
volatility right but younger you are the
more volatile you want the asset to be
but isn't the illiquidity of VC not a
good fit for a 65 year old as well yeah
I mean there was no there's no right
answer and look you know as you know I'm
a huge fan of Bitcoin so it's not it's
not the issue of it being a fan I'm just
a bit worried about putting giving it to
my mum even at 1%
yeah but it doesn't really matter enough
yeah and not in the world we're coming
in but the real point is is anybody who
has 10 20 years or less old more of
working and saving life and I've gone on
about this a lot religion is the answer
to people's younger people's future
pension is parthis is you have to have
and I think now is the time to take risk
when you're 30 you know what do you
think that allocation number is is it 1%
is it something much larger much larger
yeah 50 no you thought about 50 for a
second no I think Kevin O'Leary yelled
at me on CNBC and he forbid me from 50
percent because he said that's the
stupidest thing he's ever heard and then
I had to ask him how much of his
portfolio was in equities yeah yeah but
you see the numbers
I think realistically if I think of the
future expected return of it let's say
and again we don't know but call the
price a million dollars right which is
the paper I wrote back in 2012 so it's
so where's are they struggling around
eight ninety five hundred yeah yeah okay
so that's a pretty good risk reward
right it's already being the highest
performing asset of all time that I've
ever seen that's I think ever recorded
not hundreds that verified so that
expected return on a ten percent
allocation is simply life-changing for
anybody
it's basically a 1x downside 115 X so
it's not 1x downside right it's probably
what okay well you know absolute zero
yeah but even the chance of that yes
very very but maybe goes down 90% okay
so we'll call it zero just to make the
math easy yep so basically you can lose
all the money you put in you can lose
eight now X plus UPS and make you could
lose eighty five hundred and make nine
hundred and ninety million
sorry nine hundred ninety thousand so
that's the that's the that's if it goes
up to if it goes up to a million from
its current price which do you think
that that is something that is realistic
what would you put like how would you
handicap that lets say a million dollar
price point at this point given where we
are today and kind of how this has
played out well look in the portfolio it
doesn't matter what it has got the PI
expected return I think it could be
worth much more than that and you know
in 20 years time we're talking about
SATs and not about Bitcoin because
that's just how we work and actually
that the divisibility of it actually
works pretty well it's just changed our
head set about using decimals also but
that's that's how it will be so doesn't
really matter what the price is but
you've got at least for an asset
a 10x expected return at least over what
time period well even most price
projections would be you probably do in
ten years so you know ten x over ten
years I mean that's astonishing but
almost any asset price and the asset
class I've ever come across but it has a
chance of a bigger upside so that's just
how I think of it I also think my
personal point of view is that
everything that we know about investing
is going to change in whether
Millennials will be doing it but the
Jen's II will is I think the idea of a
corporation goes and different parts of
eight because a corporation is to treat
it as a single legal entities of
corporate as a person the point being is
that is now old-fashioned once you've
invented tokens because I can tokenize
Exxon into maybe five thousand different
income streams asset prices all of this
so I can own any part of Exxon that I
want what an extraordinary difference so
you don't need to have corporations that
complex legal structures but you can
have different types of a tokenization
of this I think the biggest change I
think is going to happen is for
financial markets is everything's gonna
be tokenized yeah and to understand
tokenization and the outcomes everything
basically it's all gonna be option
theory and arbitrage and what we're
going to be finding is we're going to be
creating baskets of tokens and we will
be looking at value baskets and you know
I sorta Mark just go about this a few
weeks ago saying this and you know the
valley versus growth all this you're
gonna be doing all of that in tokens you
know right now you know everyone's
discounts of half these tokens they call
them [ __ ] coins you know anybody who's
an investor should be saying there is
diamonds amongst all of that yeah so I
think this is a really important point
99% of them are the [ __ ] coins right
because basically what you end up
getting is like in the tokenization
world so taking real assets and tokenize
them for example the first people
through the door are the ones who they
can't find buyers in the traditional
world they're not really sexy yet
they're they're sexy assets from a
visual standpoint but the economics
don't really make sense etc they're too
high-priced there's all these issues
right and so they're the first ones are
always the ones
that aren't the most attractive and
definitely won't be the types of assets
in the steady-state what I think people
have to understand is you can't judge
the movement up to tokenization that the
kind of whole industry on the first
couple because if you do that what you
end up doing is you'll look at those
deals or assets you'll write off saying
these are bad deals these are bad assets
or they're not attractive assets from I
don't think anybody is going through
every single token and doing the work
and going to see companies and so right
what is the asset how does it work what
is your future expectation expected
returns what is the feature of this cut
nobody's doing that
no he's doing basic put this on tokens
and that is going to be a revolution
because that is coming and that's what
I'm saying is within all of this as you
say there's a bunch of terrible ones
there's ones that may have a bet that
the rule is worth taking and there's
others that are the wrong price but
there's too many tokens because people
that realize people are anchored on
tokens or currencies they're not they're
like a replacement to equities what
you're building is a new equity market
from scratch but based on tokens so the
sp500 will be the basket of voids
coinbase 500 token you know it's a
different world and they're not like
equities because they have all the
embedded components you want in it it
can be convertible it can be a bond
there can be an income stream there can
be an asset they can be a debt they can
be we have no idea
that is the flexibility and the
incredible nasaw what is coming so I
don't think the existing financial
system really exists because I don't
think it needs to I think it can change
what is your if you're comfortable
saying what's your percentage breakdown
the portfolio of cash bonds golden
Bitcoin I've always been very cash heavy
guy because I'm actually quite risk of
us because you take risk in your career
so you don't take risk in your personal
life so I've been very debt averse
always
and so and Bitcoin I've I've never had a
massive allocation over under 10% under
under under hold under ten yeah just
because it's not very racy Bitcoin I
probably did more because I'm quite
early so I didn't really know and then
it came out and got back in again and I
probably did some more so I'm just kind
of hiring eyeing it at the moment
bonds are huge leverage okay so because
I'm using them as a speculative trade
yep and that's okay I'll go in and out
of that got it and dollars I mean I this
is how my head works in 2012 11 12 maybe
13 13 I was living in Spain and the
Mediterranean coast I was building
global macro investor in Euros I was
living in Euros my entire life savings
were in Euros and I woke up and said the
dollars going up and at one forty eight
and a half against the euro I switched
my billing all my personal savings I
then flew over to the US and I ended up
buying a place in Miami and the place I
didn't came and just stop myself from
from trading to turn it to keep it in
dollar assets and I still have that
position today sound like me in Bitcoin
oh yeah I mean I just yeah I knew it was
the one trade is that bonds have been
basically at once right I mean I guess
what every pension I had to just turn a
whole lot of bonds years ago and just
left it that way
you're one of the few people I know that
you were very very bullish on Bitcoin at
one point you not lost some of the
bullishness but but basically said I
don't know and then went back to being
bullish walk us through just kind of
mentally like that journey yeah I mean
journey is very simple to me
it's look and everyone has to admit it
you don't understand what this thing is
we all think we understand we have no
real clue what this thing is so when the
fork started happening I don't know I
don't know what this means
mmm and nobody did agree we didn't know
the outcome was the outcome but we
didn't know and I said look I don't
understand this so I'm out and I still I
would have done the same had I seen the
same situation every time again I said I
don't understand this looks to me like
you were diluting a currency by creating
identical currencies now what what was
amazing is the adoption didn't happen so
it was almost like the market was
offered the ability to accept the
dilution or not in the market rejected
it and actually became stronger
entrenched you know in the original
currency yeah amazing but yes it did
give birth some other stuff like pick on
cash and stuff that's out there an
interesting different use case but
really all of that forking was didn't
change I mean everyone just said we
don't care about the floors a Bitcoin
will just work on that and we'll work to
get around the floors hence the
lightning L could network and all that
so that was that and that was 2016 17 17
from the team yeah 17 yeah it was just
before the price spike I got out at two
and a half thousand or something and I
bought it two hundred so and and then I
walked away and then
macro happened from 2017 I could see
what was going on so I was very focused
on that bonds and currencies and it was
Dan's happy arrow who kept pestering me
he he has gone from I think not
interested at all to absolutely a
[ __ ] animal and Twitter
pushing the narrative so Dan said we
need to talk about this I'm like I look
down I'm I'm too busy with all of this
macro stuff and Dan's and macro gyrus I
really respect him and we know each
other well and you know he's a great
great great macro thinker and so I said
look we'll just don't camera we're still
on religion that's the best easiest way
because I'm going to do that that crypts
a week before the got no the gold
Bitcoin week so I said I'll do it then
because look you know I'd hadn't had a
conversation with Barry Silbert that had
got me very interested more in
digitization of stuff stuff online and
how additional stuff can have value in
them right I'm starting to think about
the broader world again because I've
always been thinking about it's not like
I walked away from the whole concept I
walked away from Bitcoin for a bit
because it understand where it was but
the whole broader digitalization what
was moving forwards in my narrative good
conversation with novo got me there so
then I sat down with Dan and I just
basically saw that the easiest way to
play this big story was basically fair
coin and
so that was it I just got back in the
end yeah what do you think about like
decentralized finance aetherium kind of
the whole programmable money yeah I love
it all I just think it's a different
thing I think a theorem is silver to
gold's Bitcoin you know because a
theorem has a somewhat of a precious you
know commodity element but much more of
a use industrial use element like silver
so I I'm very bullish on ethereum I
think got overly built beat up because
literally everybody I know is building
on a theorem and again that will morph
and change in different places will get
different stuff and but so yeah I'm
extremely bullish on that before we get
into what's going on with real vision
presidential election does it matter who
the president is for where we're going
in the finance world I'm a fan of
neatness and for the neatness of the
naira that one of the narratives that
followed which is the fourth turning by
Neil Howe I think it should have gone
far left because the far left will most
likely to break the system and change
but no change it like break corporatism
break how the healthcare system works
break how the financial system works
right within that that's if you break
the system then you're creating the
seeds of opportunity for all of the
things that we we think can come it's an
innovators dilemma right you have to
disrupt yourself in order to actually
yeah and so I don't think that the
current right of Trump is doing that
he'll disrupt some of the world trade
systems but the actual destruction of
the system itself is not going to come
out of him so if I believe in that full
turning narrative somebody has to break
it and now when you talk about breaking
it is this fell like anti capitalism
type Bluff it doesn't have to be man it
doesn't have to be anti capitalism it's
great anti kleptocracy and on oligarchy
okay right it's how drug prices in
America are literally 20 times out of
Spain whose [ __ ] madness
right it's illegal it's price-gouging
and it's wrong it's how it's it's the
monopolistic power the banking system
the pension system how you know they can
have laws changing the pension system to
make sure it works for the big financial
services firms or the pension the asset
management industry that's wrong there's
people's you money it's wrong it's wrong
the oil companies and what they get away
with and what they should do and don't
do you know there's so there's a number
of different things that I think people
would be pleased to see the back of
because everyone feels like we're being
disadvantaged and it's not capitalism I
think lives of Warren's point is
well-taken it's nothing to do with not
wanting capitalism what it don't want is
what I don't want is a system that gives
an inherent advantage to another person
got it